[BEEPS]
[GAME SOUND EFFECTS]
LILIANA YU: What do the
gaming, retail, education,
and agricultural
industries have in common?
Many of them are
optimizing their workflows
and increasing their efficiency
using Google Compute Engine.
Google Compute Engine lets you
create and run virtual machines
on Google infrastructure.
Compute Engine offers scale,
performance, and value
that allows you to easily
launch large compute clusters
on Google's infrastructure.
You can run your Windows
applications on Google Compute
Engine and take advantage
of many benefits
available to virtual
machine instances,
such as reliable
storage options,
the speed of the Google
network, and auto scaling.
In this Qwik Start
Lab, you will learn
how to launch a Windows Server
instance in Google Compute
Engine and connect it to using
the remote desktop protocol.
You do not need a Google Cloud
Platform account or project.
An account, project,
and associated resources
are provided to you as part
of this lab on Qwiklabs.
This is the second lab in
the GCP Essentials Quest.
A quest is a series of related
labs that form a learning path.
Completing this quest
earns you this badge
to recognize your achievement.
You can make your
badge or badges public
and link to them in your online
resume or social media account.
Next up on your quest
is Getting Started
with Google Shell and GCloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]